the gloom autumn is gone as other
gargoyles however I think you'll find
this interesting here even we know all
about you and your amazing powers you
can see the future from a mile away you
get that funny look on your face and
then BAM a vision is boring so we were
just wondering did you foresee that
Disney was going to add a + sign to the
end of their name and change the world
one nostalgic show at a time we're sure
you did you're the one and only Raven
Baxter after all okay everybody let's
take it from the top
Disney Plus is officially here and
Millennials aren't losing it with so
many awesome shows to choose from it's
no wonder they don't know where to start
we've lined up 10 of the best Disney
shows for you and each one is sure to
have you skipping down memory lane in no
time watch until the end to find out
which original Disney series is getting
an official reboot in 2020 Boy Meets
World Boy Meets World has got to be one
of the most cherished sitcoms of the 90s
tons of Millennials learned all about
family values while watching the
Matthews family grow up together on this
small screen the series first ever
episode aired on September 24th 1993 and
would go on to air at series finale on
May 5th 2000 kids grew up alongside
their favorite characters making them
both iconic and nostalgic who could
forget about Cory Matthews and Topanga
Lawrence's epic love stories this is
just a painting this is a masterpiece
you're a masterpiece or how Cory and
Shawn always had each other's backs we
loved how mr. Feeny was always there to
offer some sound advice and how each
episode left its viewers with a newfound
life lesson Boy Meets World first aired
on ABC but Disney Channel acquired the
rights to aired the series once it
concluded its run the show was such a
success that Disney took it upon
themselves to create Girl Meets World in
2014 the spin-off series welcome back
some of the original show's main cast
and followed Cory and topanga's daughter
Riley as she learned life lessons of her
own recess one of the most exciting
things about Disney Plus is all the
amazing cartoons it has to offer
if there's one animated series that
people will never forget it
recess the animated comedy was produced
by Walt Disney television animation and
it was part of Disney's one Saturday
morning kids everywhere couldn't wait to
wake up on Saturday mornings and find
out what TJ and his besties were up to
recess aired from 1997 to 2001 however
the show's reruns lasted until 2004
recess showed us what the social groups
of elementary kids look like it
emphasized how out-of-control
kindergartners could be and how younger
elementary school kids viewed sixth
graders as royalty by the time six
seasons had come and gone viewers knew
all about the friendly and popular TJ
Detweiler and athletic Vince LaSalle and
the tough girl Ashley Spinelli the
poetic giant Mikey Bloomberg the
smartypants Frech and grunt learn and
the shy guy Gus Griswold this series
taught us all about friendship and how
it was okay to have more than one best
friend gargoyles gargoyles has got to be
one of Disney's most ambitious and
underrated animated series of the 90s
well let's just get this over with shall
we how can I be of service out with it I
haven't got all night you've got on
minimum iam with the towering 78
episodes it's no wonder that Millennials
are already been watching the series on
Disney Plus gargoyles aired from October
24th 1994
to February 15th 1997 while the series
did get canceled it remains one of the
most adored Disney series of its decade
Disney had a much more mature audience
in mind when they crafted the idea for
gargoyles which is why many of us will
enjoy it even more today than we did
before the series begins in 1994 when a
billionaire named David Santos buys an
old Scottish castle and moves it to the
top of a Manhattan skyscraper he breaks
the spell that he has kept the gargoyles
stuck in a stone prison since 994 ad and
once breathe they adapt to the new world
and help keep the people of New York
City safe this series is unpredictable
and highly addictive so make sure to
start watching it when you have a couple
days off in a row even Stephens most of
us remember the hilarious TV show even
Stephens like it was yesterday it was
all about sibling rivalry and viewers
couldn't get enough of
Louis and Ren Stephens clashing
personalities the teen sitcom aired from
2000 to 2003 and quickly became one of
the most popular TV shows on the Disney
Channel to wrap up the series the show
was given its very own Disney Channel
Original Movie the event Stevens movie
served as the series finale and
premiered in the spring of 2003 fans of
the show are so excited to rewatch the
sitcom on Disney Plus and finish it off
with the movie even steven served as
actor Shia LaBeouf's breakout role it
catapulted him into the limelight and
the rest is pretty much history his
on-screen sister Ren who was played by
Christy Carlson Romano went on to voice
Kim Possible in Disney's animated series
by the same name Kim Possible is also
available on Disney Plus and it has fans
bubbling with excitement
they love the future if you're looking
for a blast from the past look no
further because you can officially
stream fill of the future on Disney plus
the science fiction sitcom lasted for
two seasons and aired from 2004 to 2006
it was an instant hit and viewers loved
the concept it brought forth the
futuristic series followed the dippy
family all of whom got stranded in the
21st century the tippi's time machine
breaks down during a family trip
propelling them into the past where
they're forced to act like nothing is
wrong this hilarious show is a hard one
to forget it's hilarious and witty but
most of all its concept is fresh and
entirely different than what Disney
usually sets its sights on this series
is loaded with eccentric characters like
Phil's mom Barbara and Phil's best
friend turned girlfriend Keely Hills got
a cupboard filled with gadgets that are
sure to keep his viewers entertained
x-men who else remembers running to the
living room on Saturday mornings and
flipping on the TV to catch the latest
episodes of x-men this animated series
always left its viewers wanting more
which is why Millennials are already
binge watching this throwback series
without x-men the marvel animated
universe just wouldn't be the same this
series proves how successful a Marvel
animated series could be which is what
prompted producers to create future
shows like x-men
evolutions wolverine and the x-men and
that means the animated series until
today x-men remains the longest-running
animated Marvel series which just goes
to show how amazing it is x-men aired
from 1992 to 1997 it had a total of five
seasons all of which were faithful to
the original comic book versions if you
re watch this series you'll probably be
stunned at how many mature issues it
touches upon from prejudice to isolation
to racism x-men shines a light on all
these problems shaping young minds with
a positive message in the process smart
guy there's no doubt about it smart guy
was one of the best TV shows on Disney
this 90-second followed the Henderson
family as they raised young TJ a boy
genius TJ had two older siblings Evette
and Marcus who were hilarious in their
own right one of the best characters the
show had to offer was Marcus's best
friend Moe Tibbs
hey TJ a face from the outside come all
the way over here to visit old mo this
is where I parked my bike
who brought lightheartedness and humor
to the sitcom and how could we ever
forget about Floyd Henderson the loving
and hard-working single father of three
children not only ten years old TJ is
known for his incredible intelligence we
find out all about his family and their
ventures as TJ gets transferred to
Piedmont high school sitting in proves
to be tougher than algebra but TJ
siblings are always there to help him
smart guy aired on the Disney Channel
from 1997 to 1999 and it's reruns would
later appear on BT from 2008 to 2009
That's So Raven Disney Channel stars
come and go so it's totally normal to
forget about them every decade or so but
if there's one family Disney Channel
won't let us forget about it's the
Baxters That's So Raven was such a
success that it won countless awards
after premiering in the winter of 2003
the sitcom would go on to have a total
of 100 episodes originally that So Raven
aired on ABC Kids but it would later
become
part of the Disney Channel family the
plot revolves around a teenage high
school student named Raven Baxter who
has a very special secret she can see
into the future her best friends Eddie
and Chelsey know all about her powers
and continuously help her decipher her
visions in hopes of preventing them from
happening the show would go on to have
two spin-offs Cory in the house and
Ravens home we foresee that you'll be
binge watching these series in the near
future dead before becoming a Disney
classic Doug used to be a Nickelodeon
series but once the series concluded
Disney picked up where Nickelodeon left
off this sitcom has always received
mixed reviews from its viewers some kids
couldn't stand it while other side us
the best show on television either way
we can all agree that Doug holds a
special place in our childhoods Doug was
part of the one Saturday morning block
it played alongside recess and pepper in
the sitcom had a total of three seasons
and a feature follow-up film titled
Doug's first movie were you a fan of
Doug funnie tell us in the comments
Lizzie McGuire last but not least is the
ultra popular teen sitcom Lizzie McGuire
it didn't matter if you were a boy or
girl chances were you loved following
Lizzie's everyday life on the small
screen her best friends Miranda and
Gordo always had Lizzie's back no matter
how awkward she was acting and let's not
forget about Lizzie's hilarious parents
or her up to no good little brother Matt
characters like Ethan Kraft and Kate
Sanders will go down in Disney history
so we're not at all surprised that fans
of the show are jumping at the chance to
rewatch the series it's been confirmed
that Lizzie McGuire is getting a reboot
sometime in 2020 so if you love this
show now would be a good time to start
rewatching all 64 episodes what was the
first thing you watched on Disney Plus
tell us in the comments and that's a
wrap subscribe to the things for more
fun content and don't forget to give
this video of
thumbs up we'll catch you next time
thanks for watching